ich bin für demokratie und ich bin für
ausgelassenes treiben
wenn ich ein zirkus sie werde mit der
ordnung für mich zum csd
[Musik]
ja hier in berlin hat der
karnevalsverein afd gerufen und tausende
besorgte jecken sind gekommen
mit ihrem motto lied rechte freunde
stand zusammen um zusammen
naja
ist das mottolied dieses jahren können
das machen wir auch mit in die tiefe
warum sind sie in diesem aufzug jeder
weil heute karneval ist die
karnevalisten nicht wissen was mich sehr
schockiert dass die leute hier nicht für
voll genommen werden dass die vorgeführt
werden von ihnen und ich bin ich bin ein
arbeiter ich stehe jeden morgen auf und
bin selbstständiger unternehmer und ich
könnte heulen was ich hier erlebe ich
bin nur das erste mal und ich bin sehr
traurig ja ja das sind ungefähr 5000 afd
mitglieder und das macht er natürlich
schon so ein bisschen betroffen
demokratie und für ausgelassenes treiben
wenn ich ein scherz ersten von ihnen
wir glauben dem fernsehen kein brot mehr
warum was haben wir äußern was haben wir
verbauen
das können das ist so eine weitere
veranstaltung hier und sie sind so sieht
die treten hier so bitte auch weiterhin
bin enttäuscht ja ich bitte bitte auch
wenn ich das hätte öfter warum das denn
wir sind der karnevalsszene nummer eins
und wir sind hier bei der schönsten
karnevalsveranstaltungen in dieser woche
läuft der karneval veranschlagt für mich
ist das keine karneval tonne ich ein
bisschen mehr ernst
[Applaus]
er hat gesagt das ist eine
karnevalsveranstaltung hier und das ist
ja es ist die herzlichkeit in die wärme
dieses jahres
südamerikanische feeling was diese
afrika bestimmt dass eine freundlichkeit
und herzlichkeit die man in köln und
mainz in dieser form nicht findet hier
ist einfach alles entspannt und alles
ganz ganz ganz easy
selbst
können sie auch sagen in der hinten sind
welche die sind gewalttätig intolerant
können sie das sagen da hinten sind
weil ihr euch rechnen war auf die fresse
hauen wollen und ich finde die jungs am
recht besser über die geltenden regeln
die verfassungsfeindlich sind zu reden
ich hoffe dort gemütlich das ist
natürlich das problem bei dem karneval
hier es wird immer sehr sehr viel
gequatscht und so wenig genützt und so
wenig gesungen
ein clown mit cloud schneide ich nicht
wir reden nicht mit clowns na gut dann
ich auch nicht
frage habe ich noch und zwar habe ich
eben gehört die beginn hat angerufen die
wollen ihre sprüche zurückhaben
denn dass diese dienstleistung ist wer
trägt die kosten dafür werden sie
bezahlt
wie haben sie so gesehen ihre bunten
gebühren bezahlt lange sein und dafür
noch mal 450 euro kostet gerade unser
nach 30 30 den müll dieser stelle möchte
ich mich verliebe nochmal für die russen
gebühren bedanken
herzlichen dank jeder cent ist sehr sehr
gut
vielen dank für ihre wohnung geführt
wieder fällt ist sehr gut
[Applaus]
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen
überall lassen die risiken liegen und
ihr lasst jetzt das xenix ein
beschissenes autobahn
[Musik]